こんにちははじめ社長です
ですよね
うわぁ
してしまいましたん
彼もひょっこりちゃん肇社長ですね
あのん
事務所で撮ってるんですけど意外と声が聞こえませんで静かにあります東京で言えば
撮影してるんですけどもなかなか静岡に帰れないで行く意味あることが多いんで
ちょっと
東京にテックにとってやることがブラックなかなか思想家に帰れないんで帰りと
kids 動画はそこでも取れるのでここで当たります
今回はなんかこう言って本的なものをつかみ月なんだよ紹介していこうと思います
これですボタンアザラシの音区でございまーす感じで屋さんみたいなお店があってそこ
でそこでいろいろ変な感じで片っ端から買ってきたんでちょっとじゃあし
徐々に紹介していこうと思いますその第1弾として字等全て中ためねクマとかちぱ蕪と
か女かいろいろあると思うんでちょっと変わった動物のお肉とがを紹介できたかなと
思っていますそれ大蛇の新しいです
飽きるいきましょう新しいことも何かなんだろうね立ってるパンチーズこの子
うううう
うん
ポプリ飛べるのなんか可哀想になってきたよ
アザラシとみるんでしょ朝嵐って書いた
一つだけでしゃべるのは負けますね
普通
兄にお色いよいよ elc 立ってるぜのもディップ的な感じでございます北海道別
ですね
なんかね氏ならどこでも動画を撮れるんですけども
中山いえ者の夫を支え s 4なかったか翼柄シーンですよ
マッサージ文書だからた形で皆さんが一生懸命働いているわけですから
皆さんが一生懸命働いており平日に俺は隣の部屋で技らしい
の肉を食っているというわけですからね縦で食べてみようと思いますいただけます
ん
やばい+パックが新しくなってこれなと場にいた人が食べ物を食べていただければいけ
いただきます
ああ
なるほどなっなるほどレバーみたいな熱い s 基本的にレバーですねあればね
3000れば
レバーで血の味んまではいかないんですけどちょっとそういう感じの風味がして
おおおおおおおお
全然な付かないで美味しいしを得られバー付きなんてねこれぐらいはもう全然美味しく
食べれます
全然普通に食べてたんで other しつつも美味しかったでございます船 off
バンッ
二番札晒しなんて食べることないから
めったにない機会なのでちょっとだけはやっておきましょうね
まず月画像ずだろうなおいしいおいしい2に音を見ずに前っておいてあったか全然る
んっても買えると思ってる
よかったらぜひ皆さんもデュース見てくださいねそれで皆さんジャブ
後よなんちゅうお前今のビクッとああっ当たらず
はず夏らしい食べましたパパからもう
何柱に思って嘘付いてくれるんえっ
なんでない君には食べさせてあげないよ
無修これほんとえんよ吉越にゃええええ
でも僕の中から開けたくないよー
ブレーカーを超すにゃむおらああああああ
しています